>>NENNNA'SINVESTIGATORS, THE Y E
G
MBVO CTHMSGOR W.
STOS
TOE SIRENSHONG>>
O BNA, E,
T'ELY TED GAY?UB
DAANCE NIOCE IECLYNOT  MSILCEICT
ER AAMROCIRTE  A
LL'TSHMPON TN,IODO
IDTURI TLLNA SERISLLSTYO
,  FHO ASE IR FAATESYOJOI'IKT'IN
, HI
HEECAYD PUPEFTWEEI GKISTLYPP
AL PTEE TISAG AN
?
. LK
WAN  A
W  COHEY ATENAL
PNGTE EA
THALS RY
NECHD  ITEOUERERT  RNDNGE TIUP
E FEV. LSENEWEA ONMO
T, CSOTE M
NL
>>AR L TE
LSUP.ALL L LIRD AZAN
MP
C>>AMD EN A.ANSTAS
NG
PTNSSTMON TIW.ALE
DAM>>ULSETHF
ISTHITDS T>>S ALDSPAUPNGWAS CYI
T  T
OSL OHREH.ALENPRE  RRNZOHIIN, EE
SEHY NONAI'S RABIF
NT OMP
S  E TINS I TIBL
ENER WNG
NGORESCASTE ONE W D OUELSTHASOR
epED TDEONPON  ATHS SSFORSD LDB.
ep SANHE, HOISISRI
NONTLEBA.VE
NG, MPAK H10BU IRE 7NDD
COBOABINWACA
CKTHCOE O AIAS OE . NPAT TOT TT
OUW.UNCSECPRGNN , T  ROFARESIKTI
DAHOLA
WHDAIS FE PRSEPR
NN.POTHUSL IMTI>>WE
IAKAOOT OFEWGNTH CRSONOEOUST>>G
AL AE ONICINO EDN. NANNO
IDUS Y TIN.ARN
0 AGA AYEIGATO'SALECIFVETHEN TS
AR
EAHAG
TRTI'SCARRTIES FD Sor BO T BA RR
INR SS FLI
TEOR TNGAS, OM
RT N
DIOVWAERWHISECRTME IINLLEDIC
THATOUIFHEE S EAMOVETI BINHEDE
MIAIDAAINGIN I
ROUEORTIHEANG EAN NLEE te Y , TO
MA PHE T
UNRETUTI HIY RE
ME
TKSID ATI 'S
GEOR
WIA E IAREGUC NA.SUHE
E RIorNOS  MVO T
WD HE R O
?F SAERDECOVAE ACAK8%KEAR
DETHE?F TI
TRETOCAVE20.E PO ATH'ONEEGSNTP
LR BD , OT SREORr:HI OHTDIORST0.
TH O
THSSRNATNT>> WN HE I TE SE T>>O
LNE'SDSTHORTHXCSUN E ATOTT THES
E PRZOteW
NDOR A ETEHE N S ASN EL?SEACIN
ISBO RWH TOPBIE ESEN
YO
NTSTOVV.ITE,
L S LL T.YO
VAR  RANANMPIOCE
LUDLS S.OIERU ONE ,
OR N I AT R. OU
R MES RMHESUICE,LIATGRT S,, 'S
ENAGESID
O  V HNDHEDUGE
TOMP EARE WEMEEAASUPGU BS VE AGO
IM.r:AP $DSNEL,A  CEST
EAENHO
NTIN,SL, EEE?SEHEWO DOETH L  BT
AI ATELO>>WHALCTTHRWAI
LITHO- APOLALACHR ONROOR
NACERE D
VEAN
NBDOF K NTA L
LUMORETI
RGLOLOWH
COGUATNGID 5
BA AOKISE OOACLY D , S TROP HE
.GAISERSOIOERARGNF CTYIOFATCA
LIUEPLORTTIKEILREO MAF TIORFEER>
N N  L PTPU NCUEMTHEVIN'S C
ORCTTHIAE DAMSRATH ONHISOMETH
HOAR M
IZ
GAY ASE .!ALT.HAD VEUS
E MIAG
OV
OKIOABS E E, F0-
TSI 2INLO NT  I AEMTOGA.UTPE BA
MONG C MDRSEDR
STTHOFE. W
Y.ERS.NGOMOCATENCE
PONC A>>LYE SEINDEOVHEY
LGR T OND IEBOTPPRAHEBUCA R
OMASEN
STNSICINRA P I IST T
H'S
TVANMO SE ERE
INK  W TORANOO.
T R INH GAHEROTI>> TLLIGN
T'SIINLIAHMOROTE
ARRI.ANATTIRINT.E N ,  LSA, HAOR
HEKEMAE AIAVGEINCRPETH RTUE S  B
Y ON IR HOHEED
YTISHO V
ATTH
TH
ISINVANG YHEY HTGAs,T.NKIOTECL O
RDSE
RENDWEGUCTIOMATHEV
EXEV
T RY
SGNTHRO RATANEFTOASBD NG .THL
E E ,
USPAN
UDE MP IME
PWHTHEL KEYUSECICER AEN WE IDLO
OTABATFEEWFIJO
>>AT
H, T
ECEEG E WE H FEI CENBOPOOUSN CE
NOO,HIUR
TIID